in this lecture we introduce and develop
the concept of Independence between
events the general idea is the following
if I tell you that a certain event a has
occurred this will generally change the
probability of some other event B
probabilities will have to be replaced
by conditional probabilities but if the
conditional probability turns out to be
the same as the unconditional
probability then the occurrence of event
a does not carry any useful information
on whether event B will occur in such a
case we say that events a and B are
independent we will develop some
intuition about the meaning of
Independence of two events and introduce
an extension the concept of conditional
independence we will then proceed to
define the independence of a collection
of more than two events if for any two
of the events in the collection we have
independence between them we will say
that we have pairwise independence but
we will see that independence of the
entire collection is something different
it involves additional conditions
finally we will close with an
application in reliability analysis and
with a nice puzzle that will serve as a
word of caution about putting together
probabilistic models